so today President Obama spoke at the
presidential prayer breakfast he had a
lot to say we see ISIL a brutal vicious
death cult that in the name of religion
carries out unspeakable acts of
barbarism and lest we get on our high
horse lest we get on our high horse
please please do get on your high horse
when it comes to Isis America that not
only America whole world
if this doesn't warrant a moral high
horse nothing does
anyone could get in a moral high horse
above III Isis ISIL whatever it is he
wants to tell you Jeffrey Dahmer the b2k
killers Karla Homolka could get on their
high horse when speaking to Isis and I'd
say yeah I can see it
remember that during the Crusades in the
Inquisition people committed terrible
deeds in the name of Christ okay couple
of things not all Christians are perfect
Jesus was we've talked about this
according to what you the historical
context whether you believe in the
judeo-christian God or not not every
Muslim is a terrorist of course not
Mohammed was different starting off
point a little bit in first and secondly
to equate the Inquisition which is
terrible unacceptable to the retaliatory
action of the Crusades is something that
people do a lot they conflate it
removing historical context I hate that
okay but creating a moral equivalency
between the Christians of today and Isis
is is unreal
yes this is this real life so it's not
unique to one group or one religion yes
it is it is entirely unique to one
religion and specifically right now one
very powerful group in Isis it is 100
percent statistically nearly what I as
close as you can get two hundred without
being hundred percent unique it's
opposite day I believe that the starting
point of faith is some doubt not not
being so full of yourself and so
confident
that you are right and the God speaks
only to us and doesn't speak to others
that God only cares about us and doesn't
care about others that that somehow we
alone are in possession of the truth
okay um I don't even understand what
he's trying to say like if he drink a
bucket of salt water and he sneaked into
Joe Biden's medication
I don't okay if you believe in a God and
you believe that God wants to
communicate with his people you would
have to believe that he is only
approving of one's group of actions and
disapproving of another this moral
equivalency of well we shouldn't believe
that God speaks to us in not burning
people alive and then he just maybe
we're gonna say what he doesn't speak
guys just like he's not yelling I'm told
I'm a lot what I don't understand what
he's saying here it doesn't make any
sense the overarching principle that
that he's going with is trying to create
a moral equivalent equivalent see
between namely Christians he invokes
Christ a lot but everyone else in Islam
but let's go with its premise Christians
um sure there are some Christians out
there who don't believe you know in gay
marriage granted there are even some who
support to collect Isis does this to
equate what Christians in America
believe or do with the actions of Isis
or Islamic terrorist groups and I've
never said this before about Barack
Obama but I don't believe he's an
ignorant person I don't believe it's a
stupid person but to equate the two is
downright evil or it paves the way for
incredible evil if he actually believes
that there is a moral equivalency
between buying your coffee at
chick-fil-a because you like where the
owner stands or
writing in a ballot saying hey I think a
marriage should be a man woman and child
or saying hey I don't think you should
be able to abort a baby past a third
trimester if he believes that that is on
the same moral ground lest you get on
your high horse
as Isis that's evil and that's the first
time I've said that it's incredible this
is incredible you really should watch
the whole video we have it up at ladder
with Crider com
you like this video please subscribe to
my youtube channel it doesn't cost
anything and if you didn't like this it
doesn't get much better but if your Isis
watching go fornicate yourself